Протокол корейский, косметический массаж.
Входит лицо шея до кольтая шеиновартеркоев
ая зона и кожа головы.
Предварительны, так как у нашей модели на
лице есть макияж, мы ее предварительны сним
аем,
так как у нашей модели тип кожи комбиниров
анной. Мы берем средства для сятия макияжи,
медселярную воду от бренды доктор-пейс-лид
ер. Предварительна обязательно нужно снять
макияж.
Перед тем, как делать макияж, обязательно у
точняйте, не уточняйте, а смотрите наличие
воспалительных процессов, при наличии, при
щей, окна, комедонов, массаж, делать нельзя,
потому что инфекция разнесется. Предвар
ительна есть вашего клиента, на лице какие-
то воспалительные элементы,
вы должны сначала избавиться от воспалений
, а потом уже там повторно приглашаете на
процедуру,
и делать, сначала избавляйтесь от окна,
потом уже делаете массаж. Макияж снимаем,
кожу вокруг
глаз, макияж нужно снимать аккуратно, не
растягиваем по массажным линиям.
Обязательно нужно сделать домакияж, гелем
для мувания, так как у нашей модели тип кожи
комбинированы еще раз уточняю. Перед тем,
как начать, вообще все процедуры, это
опочищение, уточняйте тип кожи. Если кожа
комбинированная или жирная, снимаем макияж
только медселярной водой. Если тип кожи нас
также комбинированы жирные, умувать лицо
нужно
гелем для умувания. Наносим гей для умув
ания, равномерно ее распределить,
обязательно
растворить ее водой, в сухую ни в коем
случае не втираем, чтобы на лице раздраж
ение было. Спеневаем,
вымываем, остатки грязи, вот с лицом, массаж
мы делаем без печаток, это единственная
процедура, которую можно работать без п
ечаток. Остатки, мующего средства, основаем
теплые водой,
так как у нас массаж входит лицо шеи до коль
та, нужно очищать всю зону. Так как в данный
момент,
наша модель попросила не смывать косметику
, свек с глаз, то макияж в области глаз мы не
смываем
тщательно. Далее, обязательно нужно моющее
средство гей для умувания очищаем прям без
остатка.
Далее этап тоннезации. Тоннер первую очер
едь предназначен для того, чтобы очистить
остаточные частички грязи также моющего
средства. Второе значение, точнее задача,
это
восстановить пашь баланс. Видите, на виде
видно, что нужно очищать не только лицо шею
и до кольта.
Тоннер подбирается по состоянию кожан. В
данный момент мы подобрали тоннер увлажня
ющий от
бренда Токкорпейс лидер. Если посмотрите,
тоннезация идет именно с правой стороны. Во
время
практической части обучения, мы всегда
показываем, что левая рука, користая эксмет
ология,
тоннезация этапа, очищения именно в одном
диском, очищает только правой рукой, а лев
ая рука вам
даетесь как вспомогательное дредмет для
того, чтобы задавать направление, чтобы ваш
клиент по
процессе какой-нибудь процедуру может ус
нуть. В этот момент можно направлять голову,
поворачивать направо или налево. Также тон
ником обрабатываем и только лицо шею и до к
ольта. В корейских
тоннерах всегда база идет диалероновая к
ислота. Есть четыре вида направления тонн
ера по
состоянию кожи от акта, углажняющий, отбел
ивающий и омолаживающий. Начинается этапа в
тоннезации,
вы подбираете в состоянию кожи. Есть вашего
клиента, обезвоженность, сухость, недостат
ок влаги,
то подбираете увлажняющий тоннер. Если воз
растной клиент, то подбираете омолаживающ
ий. В омолаживающем
тоннере в составе может всегда идет полов
ина гелороновая кислота. Остальные компон
енты это колоден Эластин
Пептиды Витамин. После тоннезации
обязательно мы работаем массажным кремом.
Не в коем случае мы не
работаем маслажными маслами, особенно в
нашей клиенте, комбинированные кожи, склон
ная,
косполительным процессом. Если мы будем
маслами чисто неди работать, то горы забью
ться. Мы наносим
массажный крем от Витаминами, а доктор-пейс
-видер. Остатки перед тем, как начать делать
массаж. Остатки массажного масла разогрев
аем
в ладони, на сладоне должно быть тёблой. М
ассажный крем мы распределяем равномерно
болицу и часть
оставляем в обосе до кольца.
Первое наше движение - это поглаживание под
бородок, губы, нос, глаза, лопы, повтор три
раза, тоже подбородок, губы, нос,
глаза, лопы, третий повтор подбородок, губы,
нос, глаза, лопы. Учитывайте, что на виде
скорость чуть
завышена, а так массаж продолжительность 30
минут. Мы всегда работаем средним пальцем.
Редактор субтитров А.Семкин Корректор А.К
улакова
Редактор субтитров А.Кулакова Корректор А.
Кулакова
Редактор субтитров А.Семкин Корректор А.К
улакова
Редактор субтитров А.Кулакова Корректор А.
Кулакова
Корректор А.Кулакова Корректор А.Кулакова
Корректор А.Кулакова
По состоянию кожи после того, как вы об
работали тоннером.
Все лицо, шеи-то кольтем, наносим маску, мас
ка подбирается по состоянию кожи.
Так как массаж корейский, можете выбрать
целелозную маску в том случае,
если вашего клиента на лице, раздражение,
покраснение.
В данный момент мы подобрали гелевую увлаж
няющую маску с гелороновой кислотой.
Так как кожа клиента обезвожена.
Маска перемешивается с порошком до однород
ной массы.
Ничем водой, как альгнатная маска, перемеш
ивать ненужно.
Накладываем ее более плодным слоем.
Также по состоянию кожи, можете подобрать
алгенатную маску витамином с колоденом с г
елороновой кислотой.
Тоже алгенатные маски подбираются по
состоянию кожи.
В данный момент еще раз повторяю, что маска
применялась гелевая.
На основе идет гелороновая кислота на гел
евой основе.
Там идет два компонента.
Первый компонент - это гель.
Делороновая кислотой.
Второй - это растительные компоненты.
Видите, когда будете работать, есть светоч
ки.
На основе гелевого кислотой.
На основе кислотой.
По состоянию кожи маску можно оставить от 10
-20 минут.
На основе гелевого кислотой.